[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
اخباريون خاص ومتنوعه وبايقاع سريعا
ومختلف جدا
وبين العاجل والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم
والصوره الكامله البدايه من العناوين
ايران تلعب لاجل الحزام الذهبي في العراق
سباق انطلق لتامين الغازي في شتاء اوروبا
القارس العقود طويله امد عقبه فهل لا
ينجحوا رهن روسيا
وفي ملفات الساعه 6:30 اين البيانات كيف
ومن يحمي او يكشف حساباتنا وفي ميته الى
القراصنه والمعلمين
في يوغسلافيا منعت الكره لانهيار في وقت
هو اشجت حربا اهليه في اخر للمونديال وجوه
الاخرى
[موسيقى]
فيما يواجه العراق تهديدات امنيه كبيره
على حدودها هناك في الداخل ما يؤرقه
الفساد اغنى دول النفطيه في العالم نعم
لكنها من اكثر الدول فسادا وهكذابات
العراق دوله تحتل المرتبه 157 من بين 280
على مؤشر منظمه الشفافيه العالميه للتدليل
حجم الاختلاس في العراق يبلغ اثنين فاصله
8% من الميزانيه الدوله لعام 2021 ولا
ادله على هذا الحجم من تبخر مليارين ونصف
الملياردولار من مصلحه الضرائب خبر ليس
جديدا نعم انما الجديد هو تفاصيل تتكشف
يوما بعد اخره تقريرا جديد للمدقيقين حصلت
عليه السوشيه بريس سرقه مدبره من شبكه
واسعه من المسؤولين وموظفي الخدمه المدنيه
ورجال الاعمال لهم علاقه بفصائل السياسيه
قويه القصه ان الهيئه العامه للضرائب دفعت
بشكل احتيالي ما يعادل نحو مليارين ونصف
الملياردولار لخمس شركات لديها حسابات
بمئات المليارات من الوداع هذه الوداع
التي قدمتها الشركات تعاد اليها بمجرد خصم
الضرائب وتقديم البيانات الماليه محدثه
لكن الشركات قام صاحبي مبالغ مسطرده عن
طريق الاحتلال دون ايداع اي شيء
وزاره الماليه لاحظت الامر بدات تدقيق انا
واستفسر الوزير وقتها احسان عبد الجبار من
مصلحه الضرائب قالت انها تحتفظ بالمبلغ
تقريبا لكن تفتيش الجديده كشف ان الرصيد
الفعلي وصل الى 100 مليون دولار فقط رقم
في العموم كبير نعم لكن في هذه الحلقه
قليل وقليل جدا مقارنه مع ما تمت سرقته
وهذا ما ينقلنا للنقطه التاليه رئيس
الحكومه العراقيه محمد شياع السوداني شكل
هيئه عليا لمكافحه الفساد في وصف انه
تشكيل استثنائيه رغم ان هذه اللجنه تحديدا
اللجنه التي شكلها رئيس الحكومه السابق
مصطفى الكاظمي كان السوداني بنفسه وعارضا
لها
على كلن السوداني اكد عزمه على مواجهتي
جائه الفساد
التي اصابت جميعا مفاصل الحياه
هي اكثر فتكا من جائحه كورونا
وكانت السبب وراء العديد من المشاكل
الاقتصاديه
واضعاف هيبه الدوله
وزياده الفقر والبطاله وسوء الخدمات وعليه
فان برنامجنا يتضمن سياساته
واجراءات حازمه
ومتعدده الجوانب والمستويات
لمكافحه هذه الجارحه
كما استمعنا الفساد ملف الرئيسيه على
طاوله حكومه محمد شياع السوداني واسترداده
اموال العراقيين هو الاولويات والاسباب
التي تجعل هذا الامر اولويه للسوداني
ثلاثه بحسب موقع المونتر اولا يريد
استمرار الدعم الدولي لان يحافظ عليه اذا
لم يقدم السياسيين الاكثر فسادا للمحاكمه
ثانيا يحتاج السودانيين نتائج ملموسه
وسريعه لكسب الشعب العراقي وثالثا يريد
السوداني طمانه تيار الصدري سنقدم
المتورطين للمحاكمه ونقفوا على مسافه
واحده من الجميع لكن السؤال هنا هل فعلا
السوداني جاءت في مكافحه الفساد رئيس مركز
التفكير السياسي العراقيه احسان الشمري
يرى ان الجهاد التقليديه الداعمه لحكومه
السوداني والتلميح هنا لمليشيات ايران
بالطبع لن تندفع في خوض معارك الفساد لان
جزءا من تلك القضايا ستطاله بشكل كبير
لكن حسم هذه الملفات الخاصه بالفساد لا
يرتبط بالداخل العراقي فقط بل بجهه خارجيه
هكذا يقول الشمري فمن هي هذه الشهاد
الخارجيه ايران طبعا بالصوره وهذا امر
اكده تقرير سابق لصحيفه جرسون بوست
فاطهرون التي تمتلك ميليشيات في العراق
جاءت اصلا بالسوداني لكرسي وحتى في قضايا
الفساد فالعراق بنفوذ المليشيات انعكاسا
لما يحدث في ايران في اغسطس من العام
الجاري قضيته وفساده شبيهه وللمفارقات
المبلغ ايضا متقارب ثلاثه مليار دولار
محسوبيه وفساد هدايا ورشا ودفع اموالنا
غير قانونيه من مؤسسات الحكوميه ايضا
والحرس الثوري احد المستفيدين
[موسيقى]
التفاصيل الجديده في قضيه سرقه مليارين
ونصف الملياردولار من اموال الضرائب سلطت
الضوء كما ذكرنا على بيئه الفساد في
العراق
شرقا حيث ايراني
متنفذه عملت عبرها ايران لاضاعه الفرص
العراقيه لاسيه في اتفاقيه الاطار
الاستراتيجيين مع واشنطن
لوقف الدعم الماليه الامريكيه كيف ذلك
الحكومات العراقيه عبرعها ما يجعل تحالف
واشنطن مع بغداد على المحك دائما فتضمن
ايران اقتصاد العراقيه ضعيفا وفي حاله
فوضى دائمه وفي ملف الطاقه والكهرباء اكبر
دليل
في تصريح لنا سابق يعود الى العام 2018
نائب رئيس الوزراء الاسبق بهاء الاعرجي في
حكومه حيدر العبادي اتهم ايران بعرقله
مشاريع لتطوير الطاقه والكهرباء في العراق
المصلحه واضحه ايران لا تسمح لاي حكومه
بتنميت هذا القطاع عبر ابروعها لتبقى
بغداد مرهونه للغاز الايراني
يستملك نحو احد عشر مصرفا في العراق كما
ان لها حصصا في سته مصاريف اخرى بقيمه
تتجاوز السبعين مليار دولار ولا يخفى على
العراقيين ان زاد العملات الاجنبيه وما
يدور حولها من شبهات فساد تطال شخصيه
سياسيه نافذه
تديرونك لاداره هذه الملفات
غرفه الصخر حديقه الحرس الثوري والشاه
الولائيه تلك الناحيه الاستراتيجيه خارج
السلطه الدوله مواردها منهوبه واهلها
مشردون ولا يملكون حق العوده
والفساد المستشار في البلاد ليس جديدا فهو
مستمر منذ
وسبب بهدر اكثر
من مليار دولار سبق السوداني في هذا الملف
كله من رئيس الوزراء الاسبق حيدر العبادي
ومن بعده الكاظمي اللذين حقق انجازات
المحدوده في بعض الملفات
تشكيله لجان الخاصه بمحاربه الفساد والتي
تاخذ على عتيقها فتح الملفات وجلب
المتهمين الى العداله عاده ما تصطدم اما
بوجود تسويه سياسيه
ويغلق الملف على اثرها او يتم تهريب
والمتهمين الى خارج البلاد يعلق بعض
العراقيين امالهم على السوداني خاصه في ظل
تغيير هيئه النزاهه وتشكيل لجنه المسانده
لمكافحه الفساد لكن اخرين يرون انه لم
يذهب بعيدا في ملف في الفساد الذي تقف
خلفه الكتل السياسيه التي تدير المشهد
السياسيه
ومن التورت في الفساد الى التورط يا
عسكريا اقليم كردستان تحاول فيه طهران
صارفا الانتباه الغربي عن الاحتجاجات
الداخليه والسيناريو هو اشتياح بري كما
هدد القاده العسكريون الايرانيون وهذه هي
حدود العراق مع ايران وهذه هي حدود اقليم
كردستان العراق مع ايران تشهد تحركات
عسكريه ايرانيه كبيره قوات كبيره للحرس
الثوري واليه عسكريه ثقيله ودبابات متاهله
على الحدود والحرس الثوري حشد قوته هنا في
ماريوان وسارداشته وبانا ونغدى وبيرا شهر
وشنو في المقابله مشاهده هنا ايضا توسيعه
مقررات الاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه في
مناطق الاقليم وهي
اهدافها الحارس بعضها بالصواريخ
الانتحاريه واشد الهجمات كانت على معسكري
يلعب الدولي لكن ان نفذت ايران تحديداتها
من اين ستدخل قواتها
بحسب خبراء عسكريين فان من المحتمل ان
تتقدم القوات الحرس الثوري من مناطق رخوه
امنيه السليمانيه مثلا ومن المحتمل ان
يكون الهجوم اعلى فئه في منطقه زركاويس
وحيث هنا مقر حزب كوملاء الكردي الايراني
محتمله في السليمانيه يمكن ان تكون في
باشماخ وسيران بينا وبراويز خان وهي منافذ
حدوديه بين العراق وايران وتعد ايضا مناطق
اخوه امنيه نحولا اخر وهو محور اربيل من
قضائيه
تحديدا حيث شهدت المنطقه قصرا ايرانيا
لمقاره تابعه للاحباب كرديه معارضه خيارا
اخر مدينه حاج عمران
يمكن ان تكون من المناطق المستهدفه كذلك
بحسب المعطيات على الارض فان تهديد قائد
الحرس الثوري الايراني اسماعيل قراني
للقادات العراقيين بالاجتياح البري خيارا
قائما وحقيقيا كون المصادر تفيد بتحشد
قوات من الحرس الثوري الايراني على الشريط
الحدودي مع العراق بمسافه تصل الى 120
كيلومتر ضمن ثلاث مناطق ايرانيه وهي سرداش
بيرشار واشنويا والتي تقابل مدنا بمحافظه
السليمانيه وهم شومان سيده كان وقلعه جزاء
لعزل كردستاني ايران عن كردستان العراق
ومحاوله منهم لاجهاض الاحتجاجات الايرانيه
في كردستان ايراني تحديدا الا ان قرار
بغداد بنشر قوات من حرس الحدود العراقي
على الشريط الحدودي في المناطق المذكوره
وكذلك مع تركيا قد يساهم بشكل او باخر من
ايقافه فرضيه الهجوم المحتمله البري
الايرانيه على الاراضي العراقيه
ومن العراق الى لبنان الذي فشل في انتخابي
رئيسه للجلسه السابعه على التوالي الجسر
الذي يربط ايران ابيه معقل الوكيل والشريك
حزب الله وهنا طرق ايران في الالتفاف لا
تنفذ وهذه المره الماسيه الظل هي الوسيله
القناصل الفخريون هم من يقومون بوظيفه
القنصل عن الدوله في مناطق ليس لها تمثيل
دبلوماسيه
وبذلك لا قيود لا مصادره لارشيفات
ولمراسلات ولا تفتيش
متعلقاتهم وهذه هي الحيله التي استخدمها
حزب الله لتنفيذي هدف ايراني عمليته غسل
اموال وتهريب والعائدات لمن الاجابه
معروفه الكشف كان بتحقيقنا ان نشرت
تفاصيله صحيفه
500 قنصل فخريا حاليا وصادق متهمون بهذه
الجرائم لكن ارتباطهم بجماعات ارهابيه هو
اللافت حزب الله في الصوره طبعا او لنقل
هو الصوره استخدم هذه الحيل منذ عام 2008
بوجوهن كثيره بعضها مكشوفه محمد ابراهيم
والمطلوب للولايات المتحده كان قنصلا
فخريا متورطا بجرائم غسل الاموال غير
المشروعه من خلال الشركاته في لبنان
وافريقيا وكان مستوردا للبترول في غامبيا
وشريكا نقل الرئيسي انا باكياجامح قائمته
الاسماء المتورطه ايضا تطول من بينها رجل
اعمال اللبناني يدعى عالم ميري عيانه جنوب
السودان فخريا في لبنان قبض عليه عام
اثناء قيمته
بملايين الدولارات
وتحويل العائدات الى حزب الاحد
[موسيقى]
عسكريا دبلوماسيا وايضا اقتصاديا هكذا هو
طريق التبعيه التي تريده ايران للبنان كما
العراق ليس تحليلا وانما كلام المرشد
الايراني بنفسه 2017 هو عام اقتصاد
المقاومه هدفه وحده اقتصاديه واحده لايران
وحكوماتها التابعه وبشكل مستقل عن
الاقتصاد العالمي والفكره جربها الاتحاد
السوفيتي و نعلم جميعا النهايه اقتصاده
ايرانا منهار من العمله الوطنيه مستويات
الفقر مستويات البطاله ولنا في الاحتجاجات
الاخيره التي تشهدها ايران دليل وما يسري
في ايران يسري في لبنان بل هو اسوا وهنا
الدلائل كثيره لكن يكفي اقتحام المصارف
للمزيد ينضم الينا من لندن عبر سكايب
الكاتب المتخصص في الشان الايرانيه
الدكتور نبيل الحيدري اهلا بك سابدا معك
من الموضوع الاكثر سخونه من الموضوع
العسكري هل فعلا تخطط ايران الاجتياحي
كردستان العراق انها عمليه لصرف الانظار
بعيدا عن الوضع الداخلي والاحتجاجات
وتغيير طابع هذه الاحتجاجات للتدخلات
الخارجيه
تحيه لك سيدتي حنين ومشاهدي قناه العربيه
تعلمين انه
قراني حدد العراقيين بهذا الهجوم وقبلها
همم قصف الحوثه الثوي عده مواد كردستان
العراق على اساس الاحزاب الكرديه همم
المعاوضه وذلك بسبب
الانتفاضه الكبيره ونحن في الشهوه الثالث
لها وهمم التي لا تجاوزت كل التقديرات
لانهم كل الاحتجاجات السابقه كانت بضعه
ايام الاسبوع الى عشره ايام واين كيف ان
احمد وحيد قال قبل ثلاثه اسابيع انتهت
وهدد المرشد فاذا هذا ما انا اسميته في
كتبي تعلمين ايوان من الداخل وايوان دراسه
في العمق الامبراطوريه الفارسيه الهوب الى
الامام يعني بدلا ان تواجه مشاكلها من
الداخل هي حقيقه تحاول ان تلقيها الى
الخارج وتعلمين والسنجاني قال لولا الحرب
العراقيه الايرانيه اللي سقط النظام لماذا
لانها وحدتهم وجعلت هنالك عدو خارجي فهو
هدفي المخيل الايرانيه دوش من خارجي العدو
الخارجي على اساس انها هؤلاء كلهم
اتباع لعملاء للخاوج ولكننا المشاكل
الحقيقيه لذلك انا قلت من السيناريوهات
الخروج من ازمتها هو اقتحام
الهروب الى الامام والخروج من الازمه
بتصعيد على الجار العراقي يعني هل ما فعله
العراق يعد كافيا هذه الاستراتيجيه لتامين
الحدود الايرانيه معروف في العراق ولا
يخفى على احد
في الواقع هذه ليست كافي لانه تعلمين كما
انا كتبت ان هذه الاحزاب تاريخيا هي
مرتبطه بايران سواء كانت حزب الدعوه يعني
بقيادته
سواء كان فقيه حزب الدعوه كاظم الحائري
الذي عنده ثلاث كتب في ولايه الفقيه او
منظم حزب الدعوه الذي هو مرتضى العسكري
واعطاه المنشد المؤسسات كثيره في بيعته
وكذلك همم
المجلس الاعلى الذي تاسس وهؤلاء كلهم
قاتلوا مع ايران ايام الحرب العراقيه ثمان
سنوات ضد العراق
وغيرها هذه ايضا تعلن ولائها صراحه ليل
نهاوند مع ايوان وقد ذهبت حتى الى سوريا
قاتل من اجل النظام الايراني اذا همم
ما يعرف بالاطار وهذا الذي هو تابع لايوان
بعد خروج يا صدريه هذه ولاءها لايوان
ولذلك نحن نتوقع انه ليس هنالك تاثير كبير
لان السودان متاثر بالاطار وهو الذي جاء
به فاذا همم
التاثير الايراني لا زال متغوغلا سياسيا
واقتصاديا واداريا في الدوله والبرلمان
العراقي والحكومه العراقيه بشكل كبير وهذا
لذلك انه هو ال- ال- الدوله الضعيفه
المجاوره لايران التي تريد ان تنقل
الاسماء ايران تلعب دورا كبيرا في هذا
الضعف يعني الغاز المياه الكثير من
الازمات الاقتصاديه هي تنصب من ايران بشكل
مباشر هل هي استراتيجيه متعمده للعراق
يعني في حاجه لابقائها في حاجه لايران
لاتقاد العراق قدره التحكم السيطره
والنهوض باقتصاده
طبعا عده اسباب اول سبب هو الحرب العراقيه
الايوانيه ثمان سنوات وتعلمين كم قتل
المليون
منهم بين قتيل وجويح ومعوق فهم حقيقه روح
الانتقام من العرب يعني وانت تلاحظين ع
العرب حتى الموجودين في ايوان مثلا
الاحواز امامك عربيه ولكن كيف يتعاملون
معها بهذه العنصريه وبهذا الوضع افقر
منطقه في ايران فهمم يحقدون على العراق
باعتبار انهم كما قال المنشد نفسه انه همم
قدم مو ضحايا ايام الحرب العراقي الايونيه
فاذا همم استنفاد العراق وخصوصا في فتره
المالكي تعلمين هذه المليارات بعد ازاحه
الشبيه همم
من البنك المركزي وتحويل الاموال ولذلك
الان الصادرات الايرانيه وقضيه الكهرباء
والغاز الى درجه افاقه والعراق من
الميزانيات الهائله بالياوات الدول وهذا
دكتور
صدر منك ده همن الوقت اشكرك جزيل الشكر
كنت معنا الكاتب المتخصص في الشان
الايرانيه الدكتور نبيل الحيدري
في ايران كلهم بسلاح مختلف الشارع بالغناء
والنظام بالسلاح في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
الشارع الايراني تغير يحمل الشباب واسلحه
مختلفه منها ما نتابعه الان الغناء طلاب
كليه النسيج بجامعه امير كبير للتكنولوجيا
يغنون لزملائهم في السجون ويحملون صورهم
وحتى ان كان الغناء بسيطا بلا ادوات
فالارجل كافيه لصنع النغمات اما الاهتزاز
فهو يحدث تحت اقدام اخرى السلطات
الايرانيه الصدا مسموع لكن الرد مختلف
البنادق والرصاص والاعتقال
اما في الحرب الاوكرانيه انسحاب هنا روسي
من مناطق واسعه في اوكرانيا نصرونا وجب
السير على خطاه من اجل تحرير المزيد من
المدن كما اعتبرته كياب وفي موسكو الامر
لا يعدو ان يكون اكثر من اعاده نشر القوات
التماشيا مع ظروف الشتاء وبين صيحات النصر
في ثياب وواقعيه الكرملين الميدان لا يزال
مشتعلا ولا شيء يوحي باقتراب الهدنه روسيا
تبحثون منذ مده عن نقطه الضعف وجدتها تلعب
عليها
استهدافه تزداد حدتها كلما اقتربت درجه
الحراره من الصفر تعرضت محطات الطاقه
لاكثر من 300 هجوم من خلال الاسابيع
الاخيره مدن اوكرانيه عديده بلا كهرباء
وماء كثير مثلا 70% من السكان دون كهرباء
الاستراتيجيه ضروريه وان جاءت متاخره
مصادر عسكريه روسيه تتحدث لكن ما هو
الرابط بين كهرباء اوكرانيا واسمنت الطاقه
في اوروبا
لنعود الى الورق لله شبكه الكهرباء
الاوكرانيه منذ نشاتها تعد جزءا من الشبكه
الروسيه كان هذا قبل اندلاع الحرب اما
بعدها ولتجنب الانقطاعات تم ربطها بالشبكه
الاوروبيه لكن وللمفارقه لم تستورد كيف
الكهرباء
فالفضلته الى اوروبا السنه يكمون في 15
مفاعلنا ورثتها اوكرانيا من الحقبه
السوفيتيه الفائض في الانتاج الناجم عن
الخلل الديموغرافي بلغ عدد سكان اوكرانيا
بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي في 1991
اثنين وخمسين مليون قبل ان ينخفضه الى
ثلاثه واربعين مليون العام الماضي قبل
الحرب
من هذا الرقم في البلاد الان سته وعشرون
البقيه اما نجحوا او ضمه اراضيهم لروسيا
سكان اقل كهرباء فائده
بينما قطعت روسيا الغاز عن اوروبا صدرت
اوكرانيا الكهربائي الى رومانيا ومالدوبا
الان وبسبب الضربات الروسيه صار الامر
مستحيلا من بلد مصدر الى مستورد ملعب جديد
على اوروبا ومتى في الشتاء
اوكرانيا تتهم روسيا باستخدام الغاز وسيله
للابتزاز لكنها تطمح في الوقت ذاته ان تحل
محل موسكو كموردا القرين للطاقه كيف تطرح
نفسها كبديل يقدم في الوقت الحالي 15
مليار متر مكعب اضافيه من السعه
الاحتياطات الغاز الاوروبيه اما في
المستقبل فترى انها قادره بقوتها النوويه
وانكانياتها المتجدده بما في ذلك
الهيدروجين والغاز الحيوي ان تحل ايضا
محله روسيا لكنه وسط كل هذا التفكير
الاخراني في مستقبل الطاقه فهي تعاني اثار
الحاضر ومن الشتاء الذي يبدو انه سيكون
قارسا استهدافه روسيا لمنشئات الطاقه
يجعلك عاجزه عن توليد القدر الكافي
للاستهلاك وهنا المفارقه يعمل الاوروبيون
على مدها بالمواد والمعدات اللازمه لاعاده
لعمل المحطه
امام التهديدات قررت اوروبا ملاح خزانات
الغاز مبكرا هذا العام واستفادت من الغزل
الروسي الموجود قبل توقفي تدفقين الخطه
نجحت لكن ماذا عن النتائج غير متوقع يبدو
ان مستويات الغاز القياسيه التي تسابقت
الدول الاوروبيه لبلوزها اعطت وهما زائفا
بحل مشكله الطاقه بروكسل وامامه تهديدات
غاز توم واقتراب الشتاء تهافتت الصيف
الماضي على شراء الغاز وتخزينه في كل مكان
تقريبا الغزو خزنا في كهوف الملح في
خزانات المياه الجوفيه وامام الارتباك
دفعت الحكومات
340 يورو لكل ميدوات في الساعه مقابل
الغاز المستورد
حققت اوروبا اهدافها بتخزين الغاز نعم لكن
هو بحلول الشتاء الطلب كان غائبا الاسعار
العاليه تلك التي عرضت على المستهلكين هي
السبب الابرز وتاخر قدوم الشتاء عمل اخر
ايضا وامام ضعف الطالب الداخليه وامتلاء
الخزانات ترفض الدول شراء المزيد وفره
الغاز تسببت في ازمه عكسيه الشركات
الاوروبيه ترفض بيع الغاز للمستهين باسعار
السوق الحاليه امام الحكومات حلان احلاهما
مر التوجه مجددا الى الاسواق العالميه
بحثا عن الغزل رخيص وهو ما يرفع اسعاره
مجددا او فرض البيع بالخساره على الشركات
الاوروبيه
الاوقات الصعبه تغذي الخلافات المانيا رئه
الصناعه الاوروبيه
في معالجته ازمه الطاقه سامحه لشركاتها
بالبحث عن مصادر الطاقه بشكل مستقل لكن
المنتجين ايضا
يتخوفون من تقلب الاسعار ويبحثون عن
العقود الطويله برلين تعمل وعلى تقليل
الاعتماد على المحروقات حلقه مفرغه اخرى
تعمق الازمه
المانيا جاهزه لفصل الشتاء يؤكد المستشار
الالماني
لديها امتلات بنسبه 100% والتحضيرات
للشتاء المقبل بدات مع تجهيز اولي خزاننا
عائما للغاز من اصلي خمسه وعند تكلفه
مضاعفه عن التقديرات الاوليه وفيما تسابق
المانيا الاسواقه لابقاء خزانتها ممتلئه
تزداد القوه بينها وبين الدول الاوروبيه
التي تتهممها بالمضيوم منفرده لتامين
حاجتها من الطاقه ولكن في المقابله يزداد
القلق في الداخل الالماني من العقود
الطويله لان ده التي تسعى الحكومه
الالمانيه لعقدها لشراء غازي النبي
اسعارها ارخص مقابل زياده الاستثماراته
بالطاقه النظيفه التي من المفترض ان يزيد
الاعتماد عليها في العقد المقبل بشكل كبير
على حساب الغاز ولكن هذا يعني بان المانيا
قد تتمكن من الخروج من العقود التي تسعى
لعقدها الان حتى ولو لم تعد بحاجه
لاستهلاك الغاز بالكميات نفسها
الجنرال الابيض صديق روسيا الوفي الشتاء
اي تاخر في وصوله سيؤجلوا رهن موسكو
والشتاء شرقي اوروبا حتى الان لم يترك له
الاحتباس الحراري الاسهم وكما يتحضر الغرب
تتحضر روسيا
وشمالنا كانت الوجهه حيث لا يتخلف الصقيع
ولا يغيب الممر البحري الشماليه مسار يربط
بين الاطلسي والهذا مختصرا يربط اسيا
واوروبا وامريكا التوضيح سفينه تبحر من
مياه شنغهاي الاكبر في العالم الى ميناء
روتردام تقطع مسافه اقل باربعه الاف كيلو
متر من المسار التقليدي الفريق الكبير
يغري شركات الشحن لكن هناك عائقا واحد وهو
جليد العيب ان المسار متاح صيفا فقط وكان
هذا قبل اشتداد الاحتباس الحراري وذوبان
الجليل
هنا تظهر كاسح هو الجليد الحديثه وتظهر
موسكو ايضا لتكريس التفوق ابيكاسحه جديده
جديده تعمل بالطاقه النوويه البلد الوحيد
الذي لديه هذا النوع من الكاسحات قطعه
اخرى تنضم لاسطولها الذي يقتربوا من
الستين سفينه والجديد انها قادره على
ازاحه جلدنا ان يصل سمكه الى مترين اوروبا
تحضرون التناق لا مشكله سنتوجه لاسيا
وهكذا استراتيجيه روسيا من هكذا حلول
الصين مثالا تحتاجه الطاقه الروسيه
وشركاتها لم ترفض مصاريف شحن منخفضه ولهذا
ادمجه طريق الشماليه ضمن مشروع الحزام
الحزام والطريق والتفوق الروسي سبقه حضور
عسكري في القطب الشمالي ايضا شيدت قبل
سنوات اول قاعده عسكريه دائما مدينه صغيره
ومستقله ثمون مره كل عامين والهدف صريح
حمايه الحركه التجاريه القطبيه بحسب ما
تقول الدفاع الروسيه
في ذا فويس
تخيل ان تستيقظ وتجد ان حسابك على فيسبوك
قد تم حظره اذا حصلت هناك احتمال اما ان
الحسابه خلق قواعد الشركه او انه تم
اختراقه اذا افطرنا الاسود
اللجوء للطرق الاليه لاستعاده الحساب او
التواصل مع فنيه عبر الهاتف او عبر البريد
الالكتروني وغالبا لا يكون ذلك مشكله
التجاريين والشخصيات العامه بعمليه بسيطه
يسرد الموظفه عنوان البريد الالكتروني
او انستقرام ويجيب على اسئله تفسر علاقته
بمالك الحساب ثم ايها الطلب الى يوجه
الطلب الى الدعم الفني وخلال ايام تحل
المشكله
وهذه الخدمه السريعه على معظم المستخدمي
التطبيق خلق سوقا سوداء لوسطا لوسطاء من
داخل وخارج الشركه لاتزازي وسرقه واستعاده
حسابات مستخدمين لمقابل المادي
بركان ميلارد عارضه ازياء يتابعها 605 الف
شخص على انستقرام دفعه 7000 دولار لصاحب
شركه تربطه علاقته
عملته لاستعاده حسابها طبعا متى فتحت
تحقيقها على اثره اقامه بفصل او تاديب
اكثر من 20 موظفا ومقاولا المفارقه ان من
بينهم من عمل حارس امن للشركه فضيحه فعلا
لكن هي ليست الاولى
كيو قضيه ثانيه كشفتها كيف باعت الشركات
معلومات شخصيه عن المستخدمين الشركات
التسويقله ملايين الدولارات اذا كانت
الشركه نفسها متورطه فمن يحمي بياناتنا
خصوصياتنا سعد
يغيب عن دهن كثيرين ان قائمه الاحكام
والشروط التي نوافق عليها دون قراءه اي
بند فيها تمنح الشركات حق بيع بياناتنا
مقابلات السعيره محدده وفقا
للاستستيستا عفوا يبلغ متوسط السعر
المعلومه الواحده المتعلقه بالحاله الصحيه
26 سنه
اللافت انها الاعلى سعرا بين باقي
البيانات يبلغ سعره نقطه البيانات
المتعلقه بالحاله الاجتماعيه 12 سنه
كنت خاطبا او على وشك الزواج فيما تبلغ
ثلاثه سنتات فقط اذا كنت فقط تزوجت حديثا
او مطلقه
اما اذا كنت تتوقع مولودا جديدا فالنقطه
البيانات تساوي 12 سنترا اما العمر والجنس
ف يساوي يعني سنه واحده فقط شركه مثل ميتا
ستتحول هذه السنتات الى ملايين اذا باعت
الشركه معلومه واحده بقيمه خمسه سنتات
ستكسب 100 مليون دولار امريكي من الحسابات
النشطه على منصه
فيسبوك وتلميئات ستتحول لاحقا لمليارات
بعد ان تتبع وتحلل شركات التسويق سلوك
ملكي هذه البيانات وتقدمها لشركات اخرى
بعرض منتجاتها وخدماتها على المنصه لا
تتعد اذا تكرر لك ظهور اعلان شركه سفريات
على فيسبوك اذا كنت تتابع حسابات تنشر
محتوى عن السفر لا تؤثر تلك السياسه على
قرار قرارات شراءنا لمنتجا او لخدمها بل
تضع تفاصيل حياتنا تحت مشهر اشخاصا ووجهها
غير معروفات تؤثر على توجهاتنا السياسيه
والاجتماعيه
دعونا ان نستذكر ما حدث قبل ايام حيث قامت
شركه تويتر بتصريح نصف عاملها ولحقتها
فيسبوك وتسريحه 120000 من الموظفيها
وجه الديمقراطيون الانتقادات لاذعه بشان
قرار ماسك واتهموه بانه يعرض قدره من على
تامين البيانات الشخصيه في مستخدمي هل خطر
فيما وصفت خطته ذكر بيرج الخاصه بتسريح
الموظفين بانها استراتيجيه لاعاده الهيكل
هذا الامر طرح التساؤل هل تعني الخصوصيه
كثيرا لديمقراطيين ام يتوقف الامر على من
يقف خلف القرار
مكارثي رئيس مجلس النواب يقول لوسي جونيل
ان سايا الون للحريه لحريه التعبير هو
تهديد المباشر للحزب الديمقراطي وحلفائفه
في وسائل الاعلام القديمه الخوف اذا ان
يمنح ماسك صوتا للمحافظين ويستخدم تاثيره
على الامريكيين لدعم الجمهوريين في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الاشهر القادمه
على قضيه البيانات الشخصيه كلهم من منصته
بالطبع ولتاثير على قرار النخل الامريكي
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
[موسيقى]
الموقف لا يزال قويا رغم الخساره تاهل
الاخضر للدور الثاني في اقدم لاعبي في
الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
بهذه الروح دخل لاعب منتخب السعوديه
مباراتهم امام بولندا رفعوا قميص زميلهم
الذي اصيب في مباراه الارجنتين ياسر
الشهراني نعم خسروا المباراه الثانيه لكنه
حدودهم في التاهل لا تزال قائمه مباراتهم
الثالثه والاخيره في المجموعه امام
المكسيك تحدد تاهلهم مصير الاخضر السعودي
لا يزال بيديه متسلحا بالروح القتاليه
وايضا بالحماس مدرب الفريق اكد ان الفريق
متحد فماذا الجمهور
لهذه النقطه تحديدا ينضم الينا من الدوحه
موفد العربيه ليت بزاري لمعرفه الاجواء
بعد المباراه كيف هي الاجواء لديك ليك
نعم حنين تكلمتي قبل قليل قبل الفاصل عن
السياحه والسفر ولكن هنا السفر رياضي فهذه
الحافلات طبعا نحن قرب ملعب مدينه المدينه
التعليميه هنا في الدوحه التي شهدت
المباراه بين بولندا والمنتخب السعودي
ولكن هذه الحافلات خصصت للنقل المشجعين
الى مكان سكناهم الى المطار الى الموانئ
التي توجد فيها البواخر في هذه الحافله
كما نشاهد مكتوب عليها كروز وهي البواخر
التي التي يسكنها يشجع الفريق السعودي او
المنتخب السعودي دعيني فقط استضيف الاستاذ
علي موجود معنا يكلمنا عن هذا الموضوع عن
هذا المشروع المنثق بين الاتحاد الدولي
للرياضه في السعوديه وكذلك دوله قطر
السعوديه
مقرات فعاليات واماكن التجمعات
من نفس سلوى الى المطار جميع
الاماكن اللي تتجمع فيها الجماهير
السعوديه توفير كافه
طبعا في هنا في الدوحه ولكن الذي حدث ان
الكثير من المشجعين مش هيك الاستاذ علي
ذهبوا عبر راكبوا المترو وذهبوا المباراه
لمشاهده مباريات اخرى تقابل في ملاعب اخرى
ولذلك الكثير منهم لم ياتي الى هذه
المنطقه لركوب تلك الحافلات ولكن الذي
يضطر ان يذهب الى المعبر الحدودي سلوى او
الى المطار او الى مناطق اي يجب عليه
مغادره قطر منها همم توجب عليها ان ياتي
الى هذه الحافلات ولكن يعني استاذ علي كيف
همم تتعامل او تتعاملون مع هذه النقطه ان
كثير من المشجعين همم راكبوا المترو
وذهبوا الى مناطق اخرى كيف يمكن ان
تجميعها مره اخرى والركوب في هذه الحافلات
ونقلها الى اماكن سكناهم او مغادراتهم
جميع متوفره في جميع الاماكن والان
الباصات اللي هنا ما انتقلت تنتقل باذن
الله الان الى جميع المقرات بحيث ان نشجع
يطلع من المقر بيحصل قدامه مشروع قدامه
باذن الله ان شاء الله يعطيك العافيه نعم
يعني حنين هذا ما يحصل هنا اذا شاهدنا في
الساحه الكثير من الباصات غادرت بقيه هذا
الباء هذه هذه الحافله التي ستنقل الركاب
اذا عادوا الى هذه المنطقه ملعب المدينه
التعليميه او اديشن سيتي هناك في همم في
همم في الدوحه لنقلها الى اماكن اخرى هذا
ما يحدث وانتهى الماتش وطبعا ننتظر غدا
المباراه بين المغرب
وطبعا التي تقام هنا في احد الملاعب لا
اذكر تمام اي ملعب ولكن في احد الملاعب
وسوف نوافيكم اكيد لمشاهد العربيه
هو ضمن الكثير من الترتيبات التي تم
تهيئها ل همم الجمهور السعودي الذي يود ان
يحضر هذه المباريات وان يكون في قلب هذا
الحدث الرياضي الكبير اشكرك جزيل الشكر
كما معنا مفاجاه العربيه ليت بزاري شكرا
جزيلا
[موسيقى]
لمونديال لاعب كره القدم الطابع خاص الكل
يتابع وان لم تكن اهتماماته رياضيه فكره
انا منتخب البلديه يلعب في المحفل العالمي
وليس النادي تثير طبعا مشاعر وطنيه للكل
المشجعون الايرانيون بكم مثلا خلال عزفي
النشيد الوطني لبلادهم الاحتجاجات وسوء
الاوضاع في البلاد مضاعفات المشاعرهم
واحاسيسهم ببلادهم والمشاعر ذاتها عند
اللاعبين لكن طريقه التعبير مختلفه لم
يرددوا النشيد دعما للاحتجاجات في
المباراه الاولى ورددوها في الثانيه
قد يتم اعتقالهم بسبب الامر رغم انهم
رددوه في المباراه الثانيه وامر قد يحدث
بالفعل لانه حصل قبل ايام للاعب في فريق
كره بتهمه التحريض ضد النظام سوريا غفوري
ينحدر من سنندج لاني اكبر مدينه كرديه في
ايران مسقط الراس مساء ميمي رمز
الاحتجاجات اذن السياسه ليست ببعيده عن
الكره ولا المونديال في كاس العالم مع عام
1974 لم يحصل لاعبوا زئير او الكونغو
الديمقراطيه حاليا على مكافات الفيفا
النظام اخذها غاضب وقرروا التغيب عن
المباراه الثانيه ليفاجئ بمكالمتنا امنا
الرئيس ساحضر المباراه واراقب ما اذا كنتم
ستقولون ارض الملعب ام لا التحديد
بالطبعها شعلهم يلعبون
في نفس المونديال لكنه في تصفياته ضحى
الاتحاد والصوفيه بمقدا في البطوله مقابل
تاكيد موقفا سياسي نعرض انقلاب تشيلي
والوسيله الرفض فوضي مباراه الاياب في
استاد ناسينال الذي اعتبرته موسكو مكانا
مليئا بالدماء في الفناء
19166 مونديال انجلترا الاخيره كان قرارها
الرفض طلب تاشيرات منتخب دوله تراها غير
شرعيه كوريا الشماليه قبل ان يبداها تحضير
الفيفا دوله اخرى
كاس العالم فلاشه
الجمهور الانجليزيه بنفسه وتحديدا في
مدرسه
مع منتخب كوريا الشماليه ليس سياسيا بسبب
الاداء مفاجاه تحدثنا عنها بالامس هزمت
كوريا الشماليه ايطاليا يعني بتحتفل بهذا
الجيل السنويا لمده 30 عمل نجاحنا ان لم
يتكرر في عام 2010 عندما قطعت سلطات
بيونجينج اول بث حي لمباراه كره قدم بعد
تلقي الفريق ل 4 اهداف برتغاليه لكن لكره
القدم ايضا الجوانب وايجابيه على الشعوب
في بعض الاحيان ودعونا نعود بالزمن لاكثر
من 30 عاما
اتسائل احيانا عن مكان ليحدث في غزلافيا
لو كنا وصلنا لنهائي كاس العالم تساؤل ضل
يراود فريق حد زبت هتزيدش لاعب منتخب
ايروسلافيا الذي اضاء ركله الجزاء الحاسمه
في ربع نهائي كاس العالم في 1990 ومعه
الاف من ابناء الشعبي غزلافيا كانت
يوغسلافيا على شفل هيار وكان الجميع يعلم
ان ذلك سيحدث بسبب تصاعدي القوميه بين
الشعوب وبدات احتكاكات بين القاده
السياسيين لكن المنتخب حصل المزاج الشعبي
واعاد مشهد رفع الاعلام اعلام يوغسلافيا
في كل من سرابيو وبالغراد وزغلب لكن الكره
وجه اخر وفي نفس الوقت يغزلافيا كما منعت
هذا لانهيار في وقت ما اججت حربا اهليه
وساعدت عليها في وقت اخر عام 1990 معركه
في مباراه بين دينا مزغب الكرواتيه ورد
الصربي ابهرت اول علامات اول علامات تصدع
فيها وقتها حدثت اشتباكات وكانت ركله
اللاعب الكرواتي بوبان الى احد الشرطيين
الرساله واضحه الكروات والصور لا يمكنهما
التعايش بعد الان تشققات عمقات بعد سته
اشهر مباراه اخرى بين باتيزان بلغراد
الصربيت الكرواتيه اقتحم خلالها انصار
الاخير
عفوا احرقوا عالم يوغسلافيا رساله جديده
فقط الدوله سلطتها على الجزء الكرواتي من
البلاد
اشتعلت الحرب في مارس 1991 حينها اعطت
كرواتيا اكثر لاعبيها من حمل السلاح رات
انهم اكثر قدره على خدمه الامه باقدامهم
ما كما تفعل اوكرانيا اليوم عدد منهم
كانوا في منتخب يوغسلافيا 1990 ومضوا
ليقدموا البلد الوليد الى العالم كرواتيا
في 1998
السياسه والكره متداخلتان كما ذكرنا تداخل
وصل الى الوان قمصان المنتخبات زيو
المانيا الابيض والاسود يرمز الى الوانه
فرسان التوتن الذين اسسوا اماره نظام
التوتن بعد غزو روسيا في عام
1230 وسيطر على اراضي تقع اليوم ضمن حدود
دول استونيا لاتيه ليتوانيا المانيا
بولندا روسيا والسويد اما اللون الاحمر
فيرمز الى عالم الامبراطوريه الالمانيه
التي تاسست في الثامن عشر من يناير عام
وانهارت بعد ثورته نوفمبر عام
1918 مع تنازلي اخر ملوك هذا الهم الثاني
عن العرش والون الاخضر الكلاسيكي للالمان
جاء كنوع من الاعتراف بالجميل لمنتخب
ايرلندا الذي كان اول فريقا يدعو المنتخب
الالماني لخوض مواجهه مديه بعد انتهاء
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وذلك في عام
1951 في ايطاليا عام
1946 وبعد تشكيل الجمهوريه قرر المنتخب
الايطالي الاستمرار بنفس اللون الازرق
لزياه الذي يرمز الى شعار العائله المالكه
سافوي التي حكمت البلاد بين
1861 و
1946 ويعرفوا عالميا باسمي ازرق الصبايا
كما ان من مملكه سردينيا احدى الممالك
التي اتحدتها التي تشكيلي ايطاليا في
الستينات القرن 19 كان علمها يكتسيح اللون
الازرق ايضا امازيه منتخب هولندا
البرتقالي الشهير فجاء تكريما للعائله
الهولنديه اورانج التي حكمت البلاد منذ
الفن و
5044 وحتى اليوم
[موسيقى]
بدانا الساعه مشاهدينا من العراق ونختم به
البلد الغني بالخيرات المنهوبه تاريخه
وحضارته يبتسمين بالعراق العراق عريق
واقدم وجبه مطبوخه في العالم اكتشفت داخل
كهفا في الشمال في اربيل تحديدا من الان
وحتى الساعه المقبله
[موسيقى]